I think we all dream about having those
dates where it feels like a movie this
was quite a date things go well but then
he's screws everything up I've sent
Sadie one text today one and some light
Emoji stuff but that doesn't count
things just go down the hill from then
on
you have the wrong guy
when you got back
yes until you texted me 11 times in two
days Emoji stuff doesn't count Emoji
stuff comes Chris and Anna are so
brilliant to creating that connection I
do not believe you've got me kidnapped
and tortured all after one day
looking forward to working with Chris
again but in completely different roles
if you're a liar it's just lies and lies
and all lies are more lies it's the
sublight of the first original life
you're unbelievable honor is so
effortlessly cool and composed I've yet
to see something she can't do are you
ready
in scale of this is enormous
so many moving pieces it's exciting if
anything could go wrong
everyone does the stakes are incredibly
high it's just chemical weapons and
bullets
but it's still rooted in something
authentic in my line of work is better
being alone is it it's very Charming it
has a big heart protecting the
dog has never
have a story of taking the risk outside
of your comfort zone
and how rewarding and refreshing it can
feel to wake up maybe not recognize
yourself
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
foreign
thank you